[Music]
I'm James Daniels I'm an engineer on the
firebase team who here has used firebase
before cool got a good representation in
the room so I'm gonna recap a couple
little things so might be a repeat for
those of you familiar with the product
and then I'm going to jump into a live
demonstration I'm gonna do some coding
hopefully you know that's the live demo
warning I'm on stage in front of a lot
of people writing code you know
sometimes things happen but I'm lucky
because I have a lot of rubber ducks
here to help me out so I'm an engineer
on the firebase team what is firebase so
firebase is a suite of tools built on
top of Google Cloud at Google for you to
develop applications faster better
stronger and the idea here is that we
have developer tools we have our
back-end services we have tools for
monitoring app quality we have tools to
help you grow your application and then
the all-important part is earning we
have tools to help you monetize so on
the developing side we have the real
time database if you're familiar with
firebase that is the bread and butter
that was the product that Google
acquired the real time database is JSON
store that synchronizes in real time to
all your connected clients over
WebSockets it's pretty cool this is a
little bit of an outdated slide we
actually have a new service called cloud
fire store which I'll jump into in a
second we also have user authentication
this allows you to sign in your users
this product is free it integrates with
Google github Facebook out of the box
and
you can also provide your own custom
authenticators so if you're in an
enterprise environment you can spin up
something that interacts with your own
backends
if you already have your own custom
authentication app maybe something
legacy maybe something you still want to
keep up but you want your mobile
applications to be using firebase custom
authentication lets you integrate the
two
we have hosting we have cloud storage so
this is uploading binaries cloud
messaging so firebase cloud messaging is
the new version basically of Google
Cloud messaging has a lot of new
features and it also integrates with iOS
which is pretty awesome
and then there's remote configuration
and I'm a back-end guy I'm a developer
so I like these but there's also tools
to help you make your apps better right
so there's the test lab where you can
submit your applications it'll run robo
tests on them this is also in in iOS now
we also have crash reporting and
recently we about a year ago we acquired
fabric so the industry standard for
crash reporting crashlytics is now
integrated into our toolset we also have
all of our grow products and earn I'm
going to be coding for you so I'll skip
over those but if you need to grow your
product and earn some money check those
out so the idea with firebase in general
is we've actually ridden the client SDKs
for you right as in a way it's a candy
coated Google cloud right we we've built
these tools for you we built the SDK we
built the SDKs in multiple languages
his iOS Android web C++ unity right all
kinds of stuff and the idea is that the
shape of the code looks the same so when
you go create a web app and you're
calling the real time database
it looks similar to the iOS sure the API
is maybe slightly different but the same
shape of the code applies all of our
client SDKs integrate with firebase
authentication out of the box so you log
in and when it makes requests against
either fire store the real-time database
the user is logged in it you have those
credentials it's instantaneous it's
magic
and I'll just update the views on the
page they integrate with security rules
this is very important if you have a
firebase project maybe a demo project
where you didn't secure things you might
have noticed us sending out emails about
this scanning for insecure security
rules the idea is because the client is
directly interacting with the database
how do you do typical security if you
had a rest server right you'd in the
middle between your app and your
database do all kinds of checks and
verifications this is actually where
security rules come in so it's a JSON
structure you can go in there and write
rules there's some great examples there
but I won't touch on that but it's very
very important and then finally we added
this last year and next is cloud
functions for firebase this has been the
number one most requested feature since
it was a start-up like forever was cool
serverless but I still need a server
because you don't have compute right
so cloud functions gives you a bunch of
neat little hooks into firebase and this
is just a flavor on top of Google Cloud
functions right so this is the firebase
flavor and it just gives you extra hooks
so you can listen to a path in the real
time database you can listen to a path
on fire store you can listen for users
being created so fire store is more like
a traditional database than the real
time database if you use a real time
database it's just a JSON store
there's some caveats querying isn't
great when you fetch a data it goes deep
it gives you all the data under that
node so it changes how you structure
your data firestore we we started on
this after the acquisition we're like
well how can the cool things about
firebase be brought to Google cloud
technologies and the cool things about
Google cloud technologies be brought
into firebase so it's kind of the peanut
butter and jelly the firebase
acquisition and I will jump into this a
little bit so I'm gonna flip over to the
live demonstration I'm gonna be able
doing a little bit of coding I'm gonna
write an application hopefully we'll see
anything can happen all right
and I can't even control my windows that
so what I've actually done here is
because the Wi-Fi can sometimes be a
little flaky and node packages are a
black hole
I actually went ahead and generated two
projects and did some basic
configuration on them but otherwise
they're blank slates so what I did
actually here is I generated an angular
application inside my firebase function
so here I just initialize fire basement
directory and it asked me what I wanted
to enable I chose hosting I chose fire
store I chose functions and it created
those directories for me I then went up
and spin spun up an ng application in
the same one so if you see here we have
our typical angular who here uses
angular or has used angular alright so
angular is a framework a web framework
for building applications the reason I
chose it for this demonstration is just
because I'm most familiar with it and
it'll let me get code done better easier
quicker and maybe you'll learn some cool
things about angular along the way so
that's the angular application I
actually did a little bit of
configuration ahead of time on this
where I just configured it to bring in
the firebase SDKs so this is the angular
fire to library so with firebase we have
our main SDKs right so we have our iOS
SDK we have our Android SDK we have our
unity SDKs we also built on top of these
these smaller SDKs where they're
basically a compatibility layer between
whatever framework you're developing in
and the main SDK so angular fire is a
library that I'm one of the maintainer
zuv an angular fire tries to make the
firebase J SSD
okay a little bit work a little bit
better out-of-the-box with angular so
that means things like dependency
injection that means things like
observables rather than promises and
I'll touch on those when I jump into the
code more I also went ahead and
initialized a flutter application just a
default flutter application and I went
ahead and pulled in a couple of the
fibre firebase libraries so this is the
fire flutter libraries so similar to
angular fire we've built just a little
compatibility shim on top of the SDKs
and what fire flutter is gonna do is if
you're building for iOS it's gonna be
calling the iOS SDK that's gonna do all
this setup and hookups for you there and
if you're using Android it's gonna do
the Gradle builds and set up all the
dependencies there who here's played
with flutter less people all right
flutter is a cross-platform development
environment so it's largely targeting
iOS Android where you develop an
application in Dart and it allows you to
compile for both iOS and Android in the
same code base is actually really slick
so this actually show the flutter
application
cool so right now I'm in the flutter
directory and this is just straight off
the press flutter initialize new
application this is the directory
structure so here we have our our
dependencies this is the main project
route walks through all that develop our
dependencies uses material design it
hasn't a lot of nice things built in
there but the the main the meat and
potatoes of our code base is actually
just here simply in main dart so we
build our main our entry point it runs
the application I build my app there's a
stateful widgets that's my home page and
then there's a home page state here
which actually holds the state and that
matters for hot reloading I'll show that
in a second
and here I'm building a new scaffold I'm
including the title bar a body and then
an action button so that's actually spin
this up we can just do flutter run all
so that dash D is telling it which
device I want to spin up on I'm just
going to be using emulators right now so
this is configured to use the iOS and
Android emulator so it's building the
application you see it's starting Xcode
build here the cool thing about flutter
is is actually compiling down to the
native byte code right there's no
performance loss because it's JavaScript
or something like that where it's going
through an interpreter this is actually
rate to the byte code that compiles to a
native Android and iOS application so
that just spun up so let's go ahead and
bring up our Iowa
and our Android simulator
and this one like damn there
sometimes the Android emulator you gotta
do weird things to get it to work but
this is actually the the base template
that it built for us so what we have is
just an application you see there's this
main bar that's the title bar the cool
thing is knows the interface guidelines
for both Android and iOS at a box so
you'll note on the Android device it's a
left align title and the iOS is centered
right both are gonna look they're both
material design because we chose that
option but they're both made to look
like the native application themselves
and how flutter works behind the scenes
is this is actually more like how a
video game renders as opposed to you
know say react native or cordova or
something like that whereas a webpage
and you have to use CSS to make it look
like a native application this is
actually rendered like a video game
where it's actually painting the
elements and it's just a canvas so it's
very very fast so here this is the basic
sample application I did tinker with
that well as opposed to counter and this
is just incrementing a counter now why a
counter why's why is the default
template coming there so if I actually
go to the code and I change this
something something is stateful and I go
to my terminal I can hit a lowercase R
to hot reload those applications so you
see something something's stateful same
in iOS and if you notice those counters
I'm not putting that in firebase yet or
anything those counters are the state of
the application in that widget and I
just changed the code and the view
changed to represent that and I didn't
lose my counters I can do a full reload
with capital R and now you'll see I have
lost my state so doing certain things
you'll need to reload the state of
course but for most little minor
operations in your app when you're doing
some surgery you can just change that
hit lowercase R it rebuilds keeping that
state which is very very cool so that's
our flutter starting app let's go over
to angular
so I'm just gonna start ng serve spin up
the application and see what we have
there we go we have an application
running locally so let's get coding and
rip apart some stuff do some firebase
calls so I'll switch over to my angular
app so this here I'm pulling those
libraries angularfire - I'm initializing
them and then in the environment here
I've actually pulled in my my firebase
environment configuration so you can get
this just by going to the firebase
console and hitting add a new
application and it gives you the JSON
that'll give you the the plist if your
iOS or the JSON if your Android and you
can just drop those into your projects
the cool thing here like I mentioned all
the security is actually gonna be based
around the security rules that's your
way of enforcing access to your database
so none of this is private right it can
be right in your github repo if it's
open source it can be in the open so
long as you have configured those
security rules and that's your
gatekeeper as opposed to trying to keep
client-side secrets secret which is
impossible like you can obfuscate but
anyone can reverse it so let's go to our
component and we just have our base app
component here let's do some stuff here
so I'm going to go ahead and create a
constructor
that's
all right so creating my constructor and
the constructor allows me to use angular
dependency injection so if I go ahead
and pull in
let's do a thin dication first so I will
pull in angularfire off
backwards
and calling typescript I've been
bouncing between darts and typescript so
the Taipings are gonna get me so that's
one of the nice things about angular and
my primary like is it has a good
typescript experience out of the box so
I'm now pulling an angular fire off like
I mentioned angular fire off is just
built on top of the firebase SDK so I
have extra calls here extra candy
coating but if I ever need to call a
firebase off API I can just do AF off
off and then sign in anonymously or with
phone number or email but here I'm
actually going to go ahead and I'm going
to keep track of the user so I'll do a
public user behavior subject user
let's pull in user and report user from
there we go so here I'm actually pulling
in the type and I was pulling in from
firebase I have that installed this is a
behavior subject here and I'll touch on
what a behavior subject is here who's
here used rx of any form like reactive
programming alright a couple of you rx
is awesome you should look at it it's
really hard to grok at first but it does
I'm sure if you find a functional
programming person at your company and
they'll just rant about it non-stop so
what I'm gonna do here is I'm gonna do
AF off off state so the auth state is an
observable that emits a new value
whenever firebases off state changes so
I'm going to subscribe to this and I get
a user and I'm going to put that user
into I don't think I need this
this next year so now I'm inserting that
into the behavior subject so one of the
things about observables is as
observables are just a sequence of
values over time right they aren't
actually stateful so things like keeping
track of my current user is often
helpful to actually use what's called a
behavior subject so a behavior subject
actually has state so you can look at
the current state whenever so why this
is important is say I have a button I
click the button and it does some action
and I care about who the user is or if
the users logged in it's helpful to
outside of the observables actually pull
in the current user and I can actually
just shorten that that's implicit
or backwards right
so now let's go ahead and add a login
and a logout action that's actually
console.log that for now just as we see
what we're working with
so we'll console.log Lee user let's add
a login function and a logout function
so we're going to call this if off off
that sign-in with pop up and this
constant provider
and now we have to pull in fire race
so we'll pull in firebase as well as the
user type and here we're actually
initializing the Google auth provider
and then we're calling signing with
pop-up this this is not specific to
angularfire this is just the je s SDK
you can just ignore the a off I have a
section where you go auth sign-in with
pop-up and then the provider and then
logout is very simple as well so we're
calling off to get into that initialize
je s SDK auth object and then we call
sign out so that set and now that's add
some stuff to our HTML
all right
see what did we call it login
and I have that backwards tonight
I need something like wrong and let's
only show the login if the user is not
currently signed in so ng a user will do
a sync triple equals no so what we're
doing here is the user of course is an
async isn't observable so what we're
going to be doing is looking letting it
resolved first here working with that
observable and then once it's resolved
check whether or not it's triple equals
to no and then we'll add a login
similarly we can do a logout
all right and if the live demo gods are
good to me we see this login button
let's bring up the chrome inspector here
I said login
No
so that's the current user state and I
messed up something
Oh neat quotes yeah and the paren to
write good Co
rubber ducks at the ready so we hit
login
and now we've looked in oh the given
provider is not enabled I just created a
new project so that's actually go ahead
and turn on Google auth and go to
sign-in methods and let's turn on Google
authentication that's a good idea
so there now we're logged in and we see
the logout button being hit Lago can log
back in and you'll see here at console
out the whole user object from firebase
so we have a lot going on we got my
display name my horrible when Gmail
first came out user name everyone's
embarrassed of their first email address
right archangel is microsoft flight
simulator that was my callsign and we
have a bunch of metadata and keys here
as well as the urls so let's go ahead
and do something a little bit more
interesting let's go ahead and get some
data from fire store here
grabbing my speaker notes I don't have a
second screen so I got this little iPad
stand here it's pretty slick
so what we want to do in in getting the
data we actually care about who our user
is but we want our collection to change
based on the user logging and logging
out so what we're going to do is
introduce a couple operators on top of
our observable so we can go ahead and do
a if off dot off state so we care about
the user and instead of subscribing to
it instead of calling the current value
what we're gonna do here is pipe it and
I'm going to create a new observable
so let me import switch map
from our excuse so what we're gonna do
is we have a user and now we're gonna
turn it into another observable and swap
it so a switch map is like a map a map
just replaces something in line right
you replace it with something else a
switch map allows you to switch it for
and observable but the cool thing that
it does is it cancels all the prior
subscriptions to that prior value it
cancels everything out there are cases
where you have to be aware that side
effect but for authentication that's
exactly what we want when the user logs
out we want to stop listening to the
database at that path and instead listen
to it at a new place so if there's a
user then what we're going to switch map
it for is actually this pull in
I start from
so we're going to pull in angularfire
store module we can now bring that in
here get a finer store and now we'll
swap out the user for something
interesting so I'll pull in angularfire
store and we'll do a query on a
collection say bonuses
so we can do things like this
masterpiece
for now because I think I have something
in that will do of and then an MD array
so observables are the base concurrency
primitive in angular that's the large
reason why we built angular fire store
and here I'm actually doing a query on
the this is wrong syntax slightly
different syntax in here
so this is built on top of the Jay s SDK
in the Jay s SDK you would have done it
like I just did where you do dots
collection dots where and then build on
top of it but there is a slightly
different SDK at work here so we're
listening to the messages and then this
is a query builder so we're going ahead
and checking where the two equals the
user UID and then we're listening to
value changes if there is no user just
do an empty array for tangos
and still public
that was great
it's pulling observable
and that hair is kind of way
and now to see what we're working with
that subscribe and just console.log it
so empty array we're logged in that's
probably because of my query and then
empty array when we're logged out let's
log back in and let's see what's my UID
so let's grab my UID here and we'll go
to the firestore and I don't have a to
field so this changed to to that user I
notice something changed in the
background that was actually the return
so this is actually making a live
connection to the database
so whenever anything changes in the
database it gets updated here let's add
that to the view real quick we can just
- what did I call messages
and that again that's an async and let's
call that and we have to get rid of this
subscribe
cool
let's go ahead that's printing out so
let's go
and modify some values and you'll see
that update in real time
and that's really the benefit of making
these observable based is that's
actually doing the binding to the view
the firestore or the real-time database
is actually keeping that connection open
if I wanted to just get it once there's
ways of doing that I could just do a
gift instead of a subscribe but by
default this is a good way of
interacting with your database now what
I'm doing here is this is value changes
so this is unique to angularfire so the
value changes is just getting me the raw
base object out of the database and then
when the users logged out we return this
empty array and the cool thing here is
this is automatically gonna clean up all
of our prior subscriptions so this is
one of the powers of reactive
programming I'm doing the switch map and
if I were writing this just by myself
right I'd have to do a lot of ifs I'd
have to do a lot of else's that have to
cancel subscriptions that's a lot of
work and any anywhere where you have a
condition you're bound to mess up
so I'm going to cheat here and putting a
little low on time so I'll pull my dart
code
and of course there's a conflict
all right
so I made a small modification here I'm
actually now just Wapping out the body
let's see here and I'm I want the
incoming change so I'm swapping out the
body for a message list component the
message list is now this block of code
so this is a stateless widget all the
states held in fire store so I don't
care if I reload destroys it I'm
actually initializing fire store this is
a build method so whenever this gets
instantiated it's gonna call the build
and this is going to draw the components
so this is a stream
this is flutters like an observable
right it's a stream of values and
observable and it's an observable of
query snapshots so the stream source
here that's this argument is coming from
the fire store messages we're approved
true so fire store collection messages
we're approved true and if you're
familiar with the real-time database one
of the cool things about fire store is I
can append more where conditions on here
and they're all hands we can pull in the
snapshots from that and if it has data
if it does not have data it's loading
right so that's put a text widget in
there that says loading let's get the
count and then create a ListView
so this is really common in programming
with firebase whether it be flutter
JavaScript iOS Android you actually
include your drawing code inside that
callback right you can do some
performance tweaking on top of it but
the idea is that whenever that callback
triggers it's because data in the
database change that you care about so
let's redraw the list
right so this is now the item builder so
we send it the count this would be just
like a recycler view and Android or
ListView on iOS and we have this builder
we grab the document snapshot and we'll
do a title from the document message and
then a subtitle from the from name so
let's go ahead and save that and reload
so there we see the Wow and just like on
let's bring those back
and just like on web if I go in here and
alter things
and updates in real time
so we didn't get very far in building
our application but we got interacting
with the firestore we got interacting
with authentication on the web but we
have some next steps we could use FCM
for our push notifications so the idea
with FCM is you can register for those
push notifications it gives you a token
you could then call that token against
the admin SDK and be able to send a push
notification iOS Android and the web web
browsers that support it that's the
reason why I didn't build the angular
app as a PWA I showed the flutter is
particularly on iOS Safari doesn't allow
web push yet the app that I was building
we wanted integration with our LDAP I'll
touch on that in a second we need to add
the security rules of course to make
sure that our data is secure and then
finally with the flutter app we can
build production versions of our
application but we need to sign those so
you can sign those using Fastlane that's
a tool that I like to use open-source it
allows you to log into the Apple
developer portal pull the credentials
sign the application I'll build in Ruby
it's a cool script and we can deploy
that to earn an MDM server if we're
doing an internal deployment and that
formula allows you to build especially
for an enterprise app internal use very
very quickly if you're interested in
actually deploying your own app seeing
how you could integrate with legacy
endpoints or soap api's or do some extra
cool stuff our bootcamp on Friday
firebase plus Apogee so Apogee being the
API portal and we'll do some cool stuff
where will actually allow third parties
access to our fire store data and you'll
actually get to deploy your own
application
[Music]